Hi, Kim.
Hi!
It's nice to see you!
Thank you! It's good to be here.
Thanks for coming in.
I have a few questions for you.
Okay, what would you like to know?
Okay. First, I'd like for you to tell me about your family.
My family. Well, I have a very small family here in Japan.
I can tell you about my family in North America too.
There are three people in my family:...
...my husband and I are both college instructors,...
...and our daughter is a student.
She is in second year in a Japanese junior high school...
...and she's 14.
14, yes.
We also have an adorable orange and white cat.
She's a part of the family.
She's four years old, which is 32 years for a human.
We're a very busy family since we're both working.
My daughter is very involved in the dance club at school,...
...so she comes home quite late.
Oh! What kind of dance?
Well, she does mainly hip-hop.
She loves the attire and the clothing.
What do you do together as a family?
Well let's see, we do a lot of things together.
We go camping in the summer and the fall.
But we especially like the latter part of the fall...
...when the leaves are turning.
We have a special place that we go to in Ibaraki-ken.
...and we've kinda made that our spot,...
...and we invite people to come and rent cabins with us.
We also like travelling.
We travel in the spring, in the summer together.
Does this mean travel abroad or in Japan?
Both.
Oh, both.